...
» Ladies and gentlemen, the 14th
Librarian of Congress, Carla
Hayden.
[Applause]
» CARLA HAYDEN: Good evening!
And welcome.
We are so pleased to see all of
you here tonight for a very,
very special evening.
We have to start out with saying
Aloha to students and faculty of
the University of Hawaii who are
watching
via livestream at the Center
for...
I knew it was going to do that.
Oceanography research and
education on
the University of Hawaii's Minoa
campus.  Excuse me.  I am an
arts and sciences major.
And I knew that.  But we are so
delighted to have you here
tonight and on behalf of the
Library of Congress it's my
pleasure to
welcome you as we continue a
wonderful five-year
collaboration with the Daniel K.
Inouye Institute to commemorate
the
life, the legacy and the values
of the late senator Daniel
Inouye.
As many of you know, he valued
friendship before politics,
country before political party,
and honor above all else.
He was a champion of freedom and
fairness and he it is a
privilege for us to celebrate
his legacy this evening.
This event is made possible by
the generous donation from the
Daniel K.
Inouye Institute and we are
grateful, very grateful to have
with us this evening the driving
force behind his legacy.
Mrs. Irene Inouye.
[Applause]
We are looking forward to next
year's celebration and we are
hoping that all
of you will join us and be part
of a wonderful, wonderful
celebration.
I'm not going to call upon the
director of the John Kluge
Center, Mr.
John has kill, who will
introduce the lecture and the
panelists.
[Applause]
» Thank you.  As many know, Dr.
Hayden has brought energy and
dynamism to the library, only
here two years, less than two
years, and many of us are
excited to be part of that.
As for the Kluge Center itself,
under Dr. Hayden it's centered
on the original mission to be a
bridge on scholarship on the one
hand and policymakers and
interested public on the other.
Tonight's event exemplifies that
purpose.
Senator Inouye was a larger than
life figure here in Washington
and in his home state of Hawaii.
As a young man after the ban was
lifted on Japanese Americans
serving their countries he
enlisted in the army and served
in a unit of Japanese
American soldiers who fought
with extraordinary gallant triin
Italy, France and Germany.
On October 21, 1945, in the
war's final weeks in Europe, he
was severely wounded.
He had just taken out two German
machine gun nests.  He lost his
right arm.
He returned home with a
distinguished service cross,
bronze star medal, two
purple hearts, 12 other medals
and citations and not
incidentally a commitment to
bipartisanship that may have
stemmed from the lifelong
friendships he formed in an army
hospital with another wounded
veteran,
the future Republican senator
vice presidential candidate and
presidential candidate, Kansas's
bob Doyle.
After coming home and finishing
law school Mr. Inouye became
Hawaii's first representative in
1959, the year Hawaii became a
state.
Three years later he was elected
senator.  Part of a freshman
class inspired by President
Kennedy, which included
President Kennedy's brother,
Edward.
Senator Inouye served nearly
half a century in the senate
leaving a rich legacy that
includes the National Museum of
the Native American prominent
service
on the Watergate committee and
Iran contracommittee and on the
senate appropriation committee
he chaired in the last several
years of his career.
He was awarded the congressional
medal of honor in 2000 for his
military service.
After his death he was
posthumously awarded the
Presidential Medal of Freedom,
becoming the first senator to
receive both of those awards.
Tonight the John W.
Kluge Center at the library and
I do I
do Daniel K.
Inouye institute commemorate
senator's moral courage, public
service and civic engagement.
I would now like to introduce
our distinguished panelists
tonight.  First E.J.
Dionne, who writes about
politics in twice-weekly column
for The Washington Post where he
worked since 1990.  Also a
government professor at
Georgetown, a visiting professor
at Harvard, and a senior fellow
at the Brookings Institution.
He's the sole author of seven
books,
most recently "Why the Right
Went Wrong."
He made his name as a major
political intellectual with the
publication of "Why Americans
Hate Politics" in 1991.  It's
not a new thing.
Ross Douthat joined op-ed New
York Times in April 2009,
previously senior editor at the
Atlantic.
He's the author of four books,
this year "To Change the Church.
"  As well as "Grand New Party,"
"Grand New Party: How
Republicans Can Win the Working
Class and Save the American
Dream.
"  Our conversation will be
moderated by
Ann Compton, normer ABC News
White House correspondent Ann
joined in 1973 and covered seven
presidents, traveled
around the globe and through all
50 states with the president,
vice presidents as well as first
ladies.  We're delighted she can
be with us.  After the
conversation we'll allot time
for audience questions.  That
would be after some pre-recorded
questions from students at the
University of Hawaii campuses.
Please join me in welcoming our
distinguished panelists to the
stage.
[Applause]
» ANN COMPTON: Good evening.
Thank you.  Aloha to the
students who are watching, and
to all of you who have come
tonight to talk about the
American dream.
It probably goes back to we hold
these truths to be self-evident,
all men are created equal, life,
liberty and the pursuit of
happiness.  But where is the
American dream today?
And is there -- can there be
such a thing in a world as
Dionne verse and deeply divided
as our times as these.
Senator Dan Inouye lived the
American dream.  In fact, he
bled for it as President Obama
said in his eulogy when the
senator died.
Ross, I'm going to start with
you.  You wrote recently about
the American dream and said "it
ain't in California."
[chuckles]
» ROSS DOUTHAT: But possibly
Hawaii.
Right.
Well, that column was about --
employ, in certain ways I would
say that the state of California
has become especially in the
presidency of Donald Trump a
kind of idealized view of
America's political future for
some liberals and progressives
and Democrats in the sense that
in California you have a
situation where the Republican
Party as nationally is pretty
dysfunctional,
but unlike nationally, it's
pretty much irrelevant as well.
And in that sense, California,
you know, therefore California
is sort of not only as always
sort of on the cutting-edge of,
you know, new technology in
Silicon Valley and the movie
industry and so on, but also
seen as being kind of on the
cutting-edge of where
progressive politics could hope
to be if the darkness of the
Trump era should pass and the
emerging democratic majority
should finally emerge.
So the column I wrote was
basically saying that, you know,
while that might
be true, if you look at the sort
of sociological landscape of
California, if
you look at sort of the social
structure that has emerged
there, it doesn't look
at all like what I think many
progressives, E.J. probably
included, would argue is the
essence of the American dream.
We can sort of go back and forth
on what that essence is, but I
think most people would say it
has something to do
with a mix of kind of, you know,
a sort of strong economically
stable middle
crass and various forms of sort
of social equality and upward
mobility that sort of intersect
in different ways.
And the society that California
has,
even under progressive
governance is a much more
stratified society in which, for
various complicated reasons of
public policy and sort of
overall macro-trends, the middle
class has basically been priced
out, and so you have an
extremely wealthy upper class
that has sort of entrenched its
privileges in various ways
through land use regulations and
restrictions on building and
everything else, and then
you have an increasingly
immigrant based working class
that sort of serves as sort of
the service sector for that
economy, and you have very
little in between.  And once you
control for cost of living,
extremely high child poverty
rates, extremely high racial
gaps.  You know, again whatever
else the American dream means,
it has something to do with the
equality of the races and
equality of opportunity and so
on.
And so the takeaway from the
column, I guess, was that if
this is the future and if this
is particularly the future that
progressives are hoping to build
after the age of Donald Trump
should pass, then there's still
considerable work to be done if
that future is going to sort of
dove tail with what, again, I
think traditionally Americans
have sort of imagined the
American dream to be.
And just to personalize it a
tiny bit as I did in the column,
I'm from the east coast but I
was actually born in San
Francisco in 1979.
And I was born there because my
father was from southern
California, and he
grew up in Santa Monica in a
period when that was a kind of
middle-class paradise.
His dad was a pretty
unsuccessful small businessman,
I think it's fair to say.
He ran a bicycle shop badly and
had
various sort of salesman-y
Willie Lowman-ish jobs, and my
grandmother sort of held the
house together.  But they were
in no way what you would
consider sort of a major
American successes.  They were
sort of slightly below the
middle class.
And yet they, you know, owned a
small sort of mission-style home
in a neighborhood that was close
to the ocean
and felt like earthly paradise
and were surrounded by people
with similar means and
aspirations.
And there are automatic kinds of
sort of inevitable reasons why
that couldn't last, but it's
still notable that it didn't
last.  If you go back to Santa
Monica now, all the houses like
the one where my dad grew up
have been torn down to make way
for structures that are two or
three
times too large for the lots
they sit on and all cost 4 or $5
million, and that world is gone.
And, you know, it was a racially
segregated world, it was
stratified in all kinds of other
ways.  There are all kinds of
reasons why it's never coming
back can be, but it's
still notable it existed and
then disappeared and its
disappearance is one of the
realities underlying some of our
present political discontents.
» ANN COMPTON: E.J., is the
American dream even possible in
a society, in a political
society, that is as divided as
Washington is now, as this
country is now?
» E.J. DIONNE: Could I say a
couple things first if I may?
Whenever I'm with my friend
Ross, I feel obligated to defend
Pope Francis...
[ Laughter ]
And now I feel obligated to
defend California and his
grandfather.
[ Laughter ]
» E.J. DIONNE: I want to say
it's a joy to be
at the Library of Congress and I
am ---I am the son of a
librarian, so to have the opener
of a program like this be the
Librarian of Congress for me is
higher than having the president
of the United States here.  So I
want to...
[ Laughter ]
[Applause]
» ROSS DOUTHAT: More true now
than in some administrations.
» E.J. DIONNE: You can interpret
that in many different ways and
they're probably all true.
Second, it's a real joy to be
here as part of the Inouye
program.  This is my second
Inouye event this year.
And I got to do a talk in Hawaii
and learned an enormous amount
about Hawaii politics.  It's
great to start with a little
knowledge or a learning curve is
awesome.
But I realize, when I was
thinking about the American
dream, Inouye is part of that.
And that it's one of the ironyst
of our history that Japanese
Americans and non-whites in
general in Hawaii broke through
partly because of their service
in World War II.
And that Hawaiian politics were
revolutionized by a group of
veterans led by Senator Inouye
that created the modern
Democratic party.
So I thank the folks associated
with Senator Inouye for giving
me this education.
Last, I want to say I'm a huge
fan of Ross despite our
disagreements.  I teach a class
at Georgetown on median politics
and I realized you
better pay attention to this
online thing in this median
politics class.
My first two guests were a
23-year-old blogger for the
throng.
My first two blogger guests, my
first
opening to that world, a
22-year-old blogger --
» ROSS DOUTHAT: Surely 24, must
have been, at least.
» E.J. DIONNE: I'll double
check.
A 23-year-old blogger named Ezra
Klein.  So I tell my students
that my class is
way ahead of the mainstream
media, and I've always been
grateful to Ross for being
there.
You know, ill thought a lot
about this topic in the last few
weeks, thinking,
you know, about the event
tonight, and a really vexed idea
that, you know, it can be seen
as a kind of romantic view of
what opportunity is like in
America given the group's
history who have been excluded
from it.  But the other side of
it, and it may
be most powerful, when it's used
as a call upon us to make our
country what it
not -- what it isn't yet but
ought to be.
And sort of two uses like that
came to mind.
One was, of course, Martin
Luther King's "I have a dream"
speech and he
was very explicit in saying, it
is a dream deeply rooted in the
American dream.
And as you suggested at the
beginning, he too invoked the
declaration, I have a dream that
one day this nation will rise
up and live out the true meaning
of its creed, we hold these
truths to be self-evident that
all men are created equal.
But it also can be used as a
critique.
Many of you know probably
Langston Hughes's most famous
poem "what happens to a dream
deferred does it dry up like a
raisin in the sun.
"  And what I had forgotten is
how that
poem ends, which is what happens
to a dream deferred, the last
line of the poem is "or does it
explode.
"  And it's a sort of reminder
what can
happen when we hold up these
ideals and then don't live up to
them.
I was trying to think about,
what is the definition of this?
And I think one take is that
hard work leads to success.
That's one kind of definition of
the American dream.
The other is that the next
generation will do better than
the previous generation.
Those are sort of vexed now.
We still believe -- we're still
optimists even after everything
we've
gone through, 61% of the
population, according to Gallup
believes that young people will
live better than their parents.
But there has been a decline in
some of these numbers right at
the turn of
the millennium, 74% of us
believe that people who work
hard can get ahead.
And that fell to 58% at the end
of the recession.
And to go to just briefly to
your point, can we achieve this
in a country
so divided, it strikes me that
we will have trouble sort of
creating public policy that
might move us forward because we
are so deadlocked about what
that policy should be.  But even
our view of the American
dream is now shaped
bipartisanship, the optimism
that people had in the Gallup
survey went up because so many
Republicans switched from
negative to positive after
President Obama was out of
office.  That's on the one side.
And the other side, there is --
I was
looking at a study of
millennials, the Obama years,
African American millennials
were more optimistic and more
likely to believe in the
American dream than white
millennials were.
So it's our view of this is
shaped partly by politics,
partly by race and partly by
where we fit in the society.
» ANN COMPTON: You know, you
touch on exactly what the Kluge
Center does, and that's to
connect thought to action, and
those two common measures of the
American dream as you just both
just pointed out, are you better
off than your parents were?
And the other is, do you own a
home?
Ross, let me start with you, and
then
the Kluge answer would be, and
what do we ought to do about it?
Are you better off than your
parents, are your kids, although
they're small now, going to be
better off than you?
Are there things as a society
you think can be done to push
that along?
» ROSS DOUTHAT: On the personal
front we
just went through a really bad
real estate transaction, sort of
exacerbated by illness.  It's a
bad time to make that
assessment.  I wouldn't want to
-- I wouldn't want to apply our
particular situation to the
country as a whole.  But to
generalize --
» E.J. DIONNE: I hope this
increases your appreciation for
regulation.
» ROSS DOUTHAT: That and
speaking engagements and
honoraria as well, incredibly
important.
But, I mean, I think generally,
you know, there's no question
that over the last 40 years on
this sort of "are you better off
than your parents" question, the
country has gone through a long
period of stagnation.
Tyler Keown, E.J. knows well,
economist at George Mason wrote
a book called "the great
stagnation," describing this
long period where the median
income, which is as good a way
of measuring the sort of heart
of American life as any, the
median income basically got
stuck.  And so it wasn't a
period of collapse.  It wasn't
the Great Depression, you know,
we slowly -- we've had,
obviously, a severe recession
recently.  We slowly climbed
back from.  But basically the
story of sort of a society where
the economy for most people
seems kind of stuck and where
you aren't sort of -- you're
doing okay.
You're not in poverty, you know,
you have welfare state programs
that sort of stabilize things
during recessions, but what we
had gotten used to during these
waves of expansion, you know,
during the Industrial Revolution
and then again in the post-war
boom just hasn't been there for
most people.
And over that same period you've
had a kind of hollowing out of
community in American life,
because I think another aspect
of the American dream is, you
know, if you go back to sort of
the
people who came to visit America
in the
19th century, Alexis Philtope
most famously and what they
remarked on, well, you have a
weaker state here than you often
do in Europe.  You don't have an
established church.  You don't
have a lot of the big
institutions, but you have this
incredible community spirit
often rooted in religion but
also civic engagement and other
things from the New England
town meetings through the
culture of the Midwest and so
on.  And that has obviously
taken a hit over the last couple
generations, and there's a long
and complicated argument about
how those two things intertwine.
How is the decline of marriage
rates and the decline of church
going and the decline of bowling
leagues and all these things,
how is that related to economic
stagnation?
How do the two fit together?
But that tangle is the sort of
-- that's the central policy
problem, I think, sort of, you
know, how do you figure out,
one, how to get the economy
working better for most
Americans?  And at the same time
how do you have a
kind of, you know, sort of civic
and familial and religious sort
of -- sort of a knitting back
together of the social fabric.
And we have a lot of evidence
from the
last five or ten years that this
-- you know, that things
actually have gotten worse in a
lot of respects.
I mean, the opioid epidemic,
suicide rates have gone up, you
know, you have a decline in
American life expectancy for the
first time.
And that's sort of concentrated
in particular parts of the
country and especially to E.J.
's point, it seems to be --
there is
more sort of social
anime, mess civil in working
class white America than blacks
and Hispanics.  That's the
policy problem.
And to the extent there's a
solution, I think it lies
somewhere at the intersection of
the social and economic, that we
should be looking for policies
that basically say, well, on the
one
hand you probably do need to
find ways to raise wages, get
more money into the hands of the
middle and working class.  At
the same time you want those
policies to sort of somehow
create a virtuous cycle with
families and
communities and so on and not
just
become the kind of things that I
think since a lot of Trump
voters rebelled
against, the idea that, well,
your -- I think the Democratic
party ended up in a
position where technically its
economic policies are more
popular but people don't like
the idea, well, my community has
been hollowed out, the jobs are
never coming back, but at least
I have Medicaid.
They liked more the idea that
Trump was selling of, you're
going to get the jobs back,
ethics are going to be the way
they were -- things are going to
be the way they were before and
I don't
think that was a completely
honest sales pitch but spoke to
a challenge I think both parties
haven't been able to meet
that combined ideas sort of
solid jobs and solid civic life
that sort of slipped away in big
parts of the country.
» ANN COMPTON: Let's stick with
the economics.
» E.J. DIONNE: I think we agree
to a significant degree.
Actually I think one of the big
questions we need to grapple
with is whether that decline in
community,
family breakup and all of that
is primarily -- conservative
sense, talk
about the cause going from there
to economic conditions,
progressives look at economic
conditions and say, those
are actually fostering the
decline of community, the
problems families confront, and
in some different worlds, it
would be nice to have a
conversation
where I would continue to argue
that -- importance of economic,
but progressives and
conservatives can say, you have
to care about the family and
civic life and you have to care
about the economic base.
But I think we've had a real
crisis measured by the numbers
in social mobility since you can
date it from
1973, you can date it from 1980,
but opportunity does seem to be
sticking more to people in the
upper middle class and above.
My colleague at the Brookings
Institution, Richard Reeves
wrote a book
called "Dream Hoarders" about
the upper middle class.
And it's easier -- that's not
counting the extremely
privileged.
This is a broader top of the
society, have been able to pass
along their advantages more
efficiently to their kids than
earlier upper classes have been,
and actually I discovered,
Richard quoted something I said
over lunch in the book, and
thank God he's a friend because
he quoted something I kind of
like to repeat instead of some
damn fool thing I said over
lunch, which there were many.
But I said that I spend my weeks
writing columns denouncing
inequality and my nights and
weekends increasing it.  Because
someone effectively in the upper
middle class, whatever class I'm
in, somewhere up there, I have
the opportunity to pass along
benefits to my kids, you know,
for no particular virtue of
mine, just because I happen to
be here, and I am going to do
whatever I can to help my kids,
as all of us will do, but those
kind of -- you know, the way in
which those advantages kind of
bundle together, we have less
social mobility.
The second thing is, we have had
less
-- far less equally distributed
income
growth, that in the sort of
great period
from World War II through the
mid '70s, 1980, each quintile
tended to go up roughly equally.
Not a great period of economic
growth but shared economic
growth.
Since then we have -- it has not
been
shared at all, that the middle
and bottom has stagnated and a
lot of
benefits have gone to the top,
and especially to the very top.
And what we're discovering, this
is a question Americans have to
be tough on ourselves about, is
that, you know, in
some ways the American dream is
now a sort of demand social
Democratic dream,
which is to say that the
societies that
have less inequality tend to
have more social mobility and
that there -- my conservative
friends like to say, I'm not for
equality of results but I am for
equality of opportunity.
But what appears to be the case
is if your class and incomes,
you know, your class system and
your income
distribution gets too far out of
whack,
you lose the capacity for mass
upward mobility.  Again, this
probably reflects the difference
in our political view, but I
think we need somewhat more
egalitarian public policies in
order to produce the degree of
mobility that the American
dream suggests we ought to have.
» ANN COMPTON: I'm turning to
education now.
Both of you went to Harvard, and
--
» ROSS DOUTHAT: He wrote a whole
book about it.
Writes a book criticizing
Harvard, joins the Catholic
Church and writes a book
criticizing the point.
» ANN COMPTON: Ross, it's been
more than
a decade since you wrote so
lovingly of your Harvard years.
» ROSS DOUTHAT: A fond critique.
» ANN COMPTON: 300 pages down
for 60 seconds for this
audience, and my question is, a
decade later, any second
thoughts about your alma mater?
» ROSS DOUTHAT: Oh, no, I mean,
it's worse than it was.  No,
there haven't been second
thoughts.  I mean, E.J.
has sort of teed this up
effectively, what E.J.
was talking about in the Richard
Reeves Dream Hoarders
phenomenon, a personalized way
what I was trying to
get at in that book, which was
called Privilege.
And the argument was basically
sort of
ripped off from smarter people,
the late Christopher Lash among
others, the
system of metaphor tock si does
not, in fact, tend to be
Democratic, it tends to
create a new aristocracy that
becomes in a different way
jealous of its privileges, has
different forms of capital and
so on and SAT scores matter much
more than ancient pedigrees and
so on.
But in practice, it
recapitulates many
of the vices of older
aristocracies and also develops
certain vices of its own, like
the belief that, well, because
we're
meritocats, we deserve to rule
unlike the aristocrats.
So that was sort of it in a
nutshell,
that basically if you look
around these schools that are
there to sort of
educate the elites, they are, in
fact, perpetuating an elite that
itself is sort of both
increasingly segregated from the
rest of American society.  I
mean, that's one of the
interesting
things about sort of the
post-'70s dynamic in American
life, that you have
-- if you go back 40 or 50 years
and look at the distribution of
people with Ph.D.s and J. D. s,
these advanced degrees, they're
pretty evenly distributed around
the country, you have clusters
in each state, sort of local
groups of academic elites and
legal elites and so on and then
you flash forward to the present
era and they're much more
concentrated in this sort of
major east coast and west coast
urban centers and then sort of
college towns scattered around
the country.
So you have a kind of much
stronger segregation by
education in the U.S. than you
had 40 or 50 years ago and you
have sort of fewer local elites
that are
sort of in touch with, you know,
Iowa, New Hampshire, whatever
state they come from, and you
have this nationally elite that
is less in touch with the
country
than it would have been 40 or 50
years ago and that's a dynamic
the Ivy League schools and sort
of the U.S.
-- I mean, it's also notable
that the "U.S. News and World
Report" ranks, right?
When you think about sort of
what -- the "U.S. News and World
Report" rankings never change.
I mean, of course they change
from year to year sometimes it's
Harvard, sometimes it's Yale.
Schools can sort of work their
way up.  The University of
Chicago sort of changed its
admission policies ten or
fifteen years ago and it climbed
dramatically.  Things change,
but there's never a
start-up university in the Top
Ten in the "U.S. News and World
Report" ranking.
The newest university there is
Stanford which was founded a
mere 120 years ago or whatever,
and that in itself, I think, is
a significant
statement about what these sort
of meritocratic factories do.
They're there to sort of protect
their
own privileges by creating, you
know, by sort of reproducing the
privilege of the families and
students who attend them.
And, you know, all societies
have
elites, it's inevitable
phenomenon.
But it's still notable in a
society
sort of that has such Democratic
self-image that people often
think of meritocats tock si and
democracy working
hand in hand but they often cut
against each other.
» ANN COMPTON: I will point out
E.J. graduated Harvard before
Ross was born.
» E.J. DIONNE: Oh, God...  did
you have to do that?
» ANN COMPTON: Because I'm even
older than E.J.  But, E.J....
well, go ahead and defend not
only Harvard, but the --
» ROSS DOUTHAT: He can't defend
Harvard.  The Pope he can
defend, but not Harvard.
» ANN COMPTON: Look at the
generations coming out of
colleges now, they've got that
college degree and they are
crushed
by the size of their college
debt.
» E.J. DIONNE: One observation I
want to make
is that two of my very favorite
conservative writers, Ross and
David
Brooks, the late Charles
Flathamer
referred to as his favorite
liberal columnist...  God bless
Charles.  I find that their
critique of American society is
this close to being radical.
And if we progressives have done
something Wright, Ross and David
would
be radicals and not -- there is
a radical element of that
critique.
I would -- I don't want to go on
a long defense of Harvard.  It's
a wonderful institution.  I
happen to love it.  It was very
important to me.
They have made efforts
particularly in
recent years to try to create
more opportunities for people
of, you know, sort of in the
middle and at the bottom.  But
it is still about replicating an
elite.  And the problem isn't
Harvard.
It's a system of
meritocracy where people come to
believe that they have all their
privilege even when they
haven't, and I think the problem
with meritocracy as an idea is
not that we should discourage
people from trying to be smarter
or trying to work harder and all
those things.
It's that people develop a sense
of dessert and then they look
down upon all kinds of other
people who have not had the same
good fortune.
I have found over the years in
my long life that you can tell a
lot about someone's worldview by
whether they
think of themselves as totally
self-made or the product of good
fortune.
Now, you know, we're all
obviously a mixture of those
things.
None of this is not effort or
the hard work people do or in
fact there are people who rise
from the bottom to the top, but
it is to say not only is the
idea of being self-made a
biological absurdity, but it
also overlooks all the
opportunities that came your way
through chance, through good
fortune, through one teacher.
I grew up in a place called Fall
River, Massachusetts.  Who is a
Fall River person?
Today by the way, if I read my
Twitter
right, it's Lizzie Borden's
birthday, the most famous person
from my hometown, I think.
But I was having Ernie Munez,
the former energy secretary is
from Fall River and I was
talking to him about high school
and my dad.
One of my dad's best friend was
a
teacher at Derphy high school
and he
looked at me and said, Mr.
Delaire is why I do what I do
now.
It was a great high school
physics teacher who inspired
this working class kid to become
one of the world class people.
But someone like Ernie Munez,
perhaps to career like his, and
all of us can tell those
stories.
So in general I share a lot of
what
Ross said about the problem of
meritocracy because it suggests
to an elite that they don't have
any
obligation to give back, that
everything they earn they earn
because of their own merit.  You
know, grace doesn't enter into
it.  Luck doesn't enter into it.
Someone else's generosity
doesn't enter into it.  The help
from the state doesn't enter
into it.
I'll close with one of my
favorite tweets I ever sent out,
which was during the Republican
convention and Chris Christie
was giving a speech about his
father going to Rutgers, a state
university, on the GI bill, a
government program.  And it was
a friendly tweet.
"It's lovely to see Chris
Christie acknowledge the role of
government in his father's life.
"
» ANN COMPTON: Well, I want to
switch
over to the overarching current
theme
that agented my life as a
reporter for ABC News over the
course of seven presidents.
The digital age has changed so
much in our society.
I look at not only how my kids
communicate, what they read, how
they communicate, but also how
Americans sometimes withdraw
from personal communications,
how they rely on
information that doesn't have
the same kind of good bones
structure of the
reporting of The Washington
Post, New York Times, ABC News
as it once was.  The digital age
has changed everything, hasn't
it, Ross?
» ROSS DOUTHAT: Yes.
Although one thing it hasn't
changed
is sort of the economic
landscape to the degree that
people thought it would.  I
mean, this is one of the
interesting -- it's not a
paradox, but it's an interesting
tension, which is that the
digital age is sort of -- it's
where
everything has ended up poured,
and other areas of innovation
and technological progress and
so on have
tended to wither a bit as we've
focused
more and more of our energy and
interest on these tiny low end
screens.
And one of the -- there's an
economist
Robert Gordon who wrote a book
something
like "The Rise and Fall of
American Growth" and one of the
points at the end was that
American growth historically
was incredibly diversified, you
had growth in energy there and
growth in construction over
there and so on.
And the digital age is much
narrower
and a sense it sort of
recapitulates in
the economy what it does to us
psychologically.
It's a colonizer of our psyche
and
focus and attention and also
sort of absorbed a lot of, I
think, sort of energy and
interest that 50 years ago would
have been more diversified, sort
of spread out more across the
economy.
So that's the only counter
intuitive point that I would
make on the change to everything
point.
I think to the question, I mean,
what
-- this is sort of the big
unanswered social question of
American life over
the next 40 or 507 years, to
what extent is digital media a
potential substitute for the
decline of community that E.J.
and I I think generally agree is
a real
problem in American life, to
what extent is social media and
sort of the communities that
form online sort of
substitutes for the decline of,
you
know, Elks lodges and churches
and so
on, to what extent is online
dating an effective substitute
for the decline of real-world
sort of institutions that
brought men and women together.
Or to what extent is it a sort
of hollow substitute basically.
And since I'm conservative and
critical and pessimistic, I tend
to sort of emphasize the extent
to which it
might be a sort of hollow
substitute,
that, you know, of course people
do fall in love online and make
friends online and all these
things but very often they find
themselves with online friends,
and, you know, a sort of online
life that seems to make
teenagers, for instance, more
depressed than their peers were
20 years ago.  But we're really
early in the experiment and you
can argue against me and say,
well, these things are just
getting off the ground, people
are just learning to live
online, it's's a disruptive
technology, people will get use
to it and then it will actually
supply the community that we
need.  But that's the question I
think that is hanging over
American society and obviously
not just American society going
forward.
Especially for people younger
than me.
» ANN COMPTON: E.J.
» E.J. DIONNE: It's funny when I
think about I know so many
younger people and even
some older people who are, you
know -- who lost their spouses,
got divorced, who met through
online dating and I sometimes
wonder, that's probably more
sensible than meeting in a bar.
Which is better?  People come to
each other with more
information...  I met my wife on
the D.C. Metro.  And so I always
like to say, I really am a
liberal.
I owe a great deal to public
transportation and the agency of
government.
And we've been together a long
time.
I didn't want to give it away,
the conservative answer, but I
thought actually you were going
to give it, which is nothing
about this technology changes
human nature.
I think one of the things Ross
and I broadly agree on is that
human nature is something given.
You can alter the way people
behave, and perhaps over time
this affects the way our
consciousness works, but it
doesn't change that.
And there's a lot of me that
wants to
fight the idea that technology
alters us
in all of these radical ways,
and yet some of the change is
undeniable.
And so much of it is how we
educate ourselves to use this
media.
So on the one hand, the parody
is of people whose entire friend
groups are sort of online,
people don't talk to each other
face-to-face.
But the other side of that is
online is often a way in which
people organize themselves for
actual social encounters
to create opportunities for
face-to-face engagement,
neighborhoods have used
technology to try to bring
people together.
If you think back to the Obama
campaign in '08, which was very
innovative, a lot of it began
online but ended with a door
knock, which is the
most infamous kind -- most
intimate kind of -- a real human
connection being made.  And I do
think it will -- and I agree
with Ross, I think I'm
influenced by the same book,
that we have to ask ourselves,
does this -- has this technology
yet changed our lives the way
the invention of the light bulb
or the automobile or the
telephone did or not?
And we probably can debate some
of those things.
What I do worry is will we be
innovative enough as a society
to replace all the jobs that are
potentially lost?
And while we have been talking
about
automation since the '50s and
'60s, you
sense that that process of job
destruction could be sped up and
the question is, will we be
innovative enough to create work
or will the economy create work
that will make up for that?
I'm reminded a great wall to --
I can't remember if it was Ford
or GM.  We'll say GM.
GM took Ruther, the head of the
auto workers into a brand-new
plant with all
these robots and machines, and
the GM
guy says to Walter Ruther, these
robots
won't be paying UAW dues and
Ruther shot
back, yeah, and they won't be
buying GM cars either.  And I
think that is a kind of struggle
we're going to have going
forward.
» ANN COMPTON: I want to ask one
more question before we open
this up to questions not only
from the audience but from the
students in Hawaii.
It was suggested to me that one
of the
good ways to look forward here,
especially since both of you
have connections to and contact
with the
younger people, young students,
journalists, how are millennials
rethinking their own view of the
American dream?  Let me start
with you, E.J.
Or do they think about it?
» E.J. DIONNE: There is some
evidence -- I talked to
political poll administers who
have said that the -- pollsters
who have said that the American
dream idea does not resonate
with younger voters, with
younger Americans in the way
that it does with older folks,
although this
data on the difference between,
you know, African Americans and
Latinos on the one side and
whites on the other
suggests it's an even more
complicated story.
But I think there is a -- you
know, I
have three kids in their 20s
that I have taught -- I've been
teaching now 15 years and have
had really awesome students.
And my sense from them -- so I'm
not
going to make it any more than
that, is
that there is, for good reason,
a somewhat -- slightly less
optimism about their way
forward.
They feel like they have had
difficulties thrown at them that
were not thrown at someone my
age.
You know, I was born in 1952 and
sort
of reached adulthood in one of
the most extraordinary periods
of growth and opportunity in our
country's history.
And actually during the '90s
when my
kids were little, I thought,
gee, maybe by delaying having
kids I really lucked out and
brought my kids into a world
that will match that great
period.
And then, you know, came 9/11,
the wars, and then the economic
collapse.
And so my sense is that there is
still a lot of -- I mean, you
know, young people have not lost
a natural sense of
optimism, but I think there is a
stronger sense of, you know, the
obstacles that they face, and
not the
easy sense that we got of, when
I was a kid, that America was
literally sitting on top of the
world.  You know, you think of
all that optimism and call to
service in the Kennedy years
that this is something
different.
» ANN COMPTON: Ross, take a
swing at this before we actually
get questions.
» ROSS DOUTHAT: Sure, I think
E.J. is right.
I think there -- if you think of
the millennial generation of
people who came of age after
2001, you know, we have been
talking about a 40 or 50-year
stagnation, but really the worst
of it economically, setting
aside war and terrorism and
everything else, has been the
last 15 years.
And if that's your experience of
sort
of entering adulthood, entering
consciousness as an American and
so on, you are naturally going
to be, I think, more pessimistic
about your prospects because
your prospects have been worse,
worse by far than your
generation and somewhat worse
than my cohort.
Although 9/11 happened my senior
year
of college, so there was --
there was a decline in the
number of consulting jobs
that my fellow meritocrats were
able to take.  That was our
great tragedy.  Thank you for
laughing.
The irony rather than taking it
seriously.
But I would also say, I think
this
thing to try to we've together
the community and Internet
questions together a little bit
one of the striking things
millennials and whatever we're
call post-millennials, in
certain respects they are the
best behaved generation in
modern American history in
terms of drug use, teen
pregnancy, car accidents, all of
-- you know, this sort of
laundry list of things that
people
worry about teenagers and early
20-somethings getting up to,
this cohort is incredibly
well-behaved.
But that sort of good behavior
coexists with a -- first of all,
a certain -- a higher degree of
unhappiness, which may be rooted
in economic factors, may be
rooted in sort of, you know, the
digital age and the anxieties it
produces, and one of the reasons
they're so well-behaved, you can
socialize online, so you're less
likely to take the car out and
get drunk with your friends.
You're less -- you know, there's
less teen sex because perhaps
there's more sexting.  It sounds
like a joke but it's actually
probably statistically not.
So you have this question, one,
you know, is the greater safety
worth perhaps the cost in
happiness?  And, two, this
connects to the
economic as well, are
millennials just sort of delayed
in -- you know, the basics of --
the American dream when you were
a kid, you know, you get
married, you have kids, you own
a home, you know, you own a car,
you own a couple of cars.
If those sort of visceral
aspects, the American dream
circa 1957, millennials are
getting married at lower rates,
buying homes at lower rates,
they are driving at lower rates.
All of these things that sort of
culturally we associate with
American normalcy aren't
happening to the same degree.
And so the question hanging over
the next 20 years will be, are
millennials
going to do all the same things
that E.J.'s Jenn ration did just
ten or fifteen years later or is
there a real shift, not in human
nature but human nature response
to the economy and everything
else, across the lifecycle
millennials less likely to have
kids and more likely to be
single and live in apartments
rather than suburban houses.
Something we won't know for
fifteen years or so.
» E.J. DIONNE: And other thing
about millennials, they are a
progressive generation, probably
the most progressive generation
since the new dealers of the
greatest generation.  Some of
that is because they are a more
Dionne verse generation.
You know -- diverse generation,
people
under 40 or 35, larger
percentage African American,
Asians.  But significantly more
liberal than cohorts and whites.
I tell children, when my
generation is gone and your
generation takes over, this will
problem be a more progressive
country.  The only problem with
that is I want to be around to
see the country when you guys
take over, so I'm going to have
the figure out a way to solve
that.
» ROSS DOUTHAT: Silicon Valley
is looking on...
» E.J. DIONNE: They're more
tolerant, they are open.
I mean, there are some very
interesting characteristics
about them
that make them a potential
political -- that may be
harbingers of political
change when they start voting in
fours.
» ANN COMPTON: One of the
beautiful parts of this program
every year is because we are
linked up to students in Hawaii
and they have offered the two of
you some really interesting
questions.
The first question we're going
to hear is from Shannon.
» Hi, I'm Shannon.
I'm a communications student at
UH,
and my idea of the American
dream is a place where people
can live happy and safely in a
community with friends and
family.  My question is:  What
do you think our generation can
do to make sure that we live
happy and healthier today?
» E.J. DIONNE: Oh, preach, Ross.
Go ahead.
» ROSS DOUTHAT: My non-partisan
answer as you can tell from
things I already said is that
you should spend less time on
the Internet.  That's without
getting into sort of whether you
should convert to Catholicism or
which kind of Catholic you
should be.
That's obviously important, but
in a non-sectarian way I would
say there is a lot of evidence.
It's not dispositive, but
there's a
lot of reasonable evidence that
social
life online is potentially more
likely to lead to depression,
unhappiness, isolation, and less
likely to lead to
healthy friendships, healthy
relationships, healthy marriages
and so on.
And, of course, you are -- you
know, I'm still young enough
hopefully to know this
reasonably well.
Of course, you can't sort of
become a
hermit and a Ludite and opt out
of the
social world of young people is
an online social world.
But figuring out how to have
your relationships and
friendships and your connection
to the world at large mediated
through old-fashioned reality
rather than digital reality
seems like a really important
step that either today's
millennials or the generation
after them is going to have to
figure
out to get to the -- to get to
the point where their
relationship and all of our
relationship to technology
becomes a healthy one.
So that's -- yeah, that's the
non-sectarian.
» E.J. DIONNE: I think I
actually agree with every single
word you said.
And I do think that sort of --
I'm not Ludite.   I love the
technology.  I spend too much
time on my phone like everyone
else does.  I can find out if
the Red Sox are winning or not,
which is very satisfying,
especially this season.
So I am very much anti-Luddite,
but I do
think that, again, there is
evidence
that if you are involved in
politics or service or religious
congregation or
sports teams or a whole series
of other
activities with other people
direct face-to-face, that that's
a helpful thing.
The other virtue I have sort of
toyed with a lot, I thought
about a lot, because it's a
really complicated virtue, is
virtue of loyalty.
And I worry a lot about, on the
one hand loyalty can be
misplaced.
Loyalty can demand, you know,
the -- I
mean, I think they have loyalty
in their slow gone, which
reminds me, don't much too much
on that.  On the other hand, I
worry about a society that has
lost a sense of loyalty.
Maybe this is from, you know,
I'm from Massachusetts where --
and loyalties are
so strong that the most powerful
-- you know, the old joke about
the version of Alzheimer's, you
forget everything except your
grudges.  If somebody was on the
wrong team.  But I do think that
there is -- I
worry about the decline of
loyalty in this society from
employee to employee from
employee to employer, our
loyalties to each other.
It's how do we strengthen some
of the bonds between us?
How do we stick with each other
when things get tough?  How can
friendship be demanding and not
temporary, not just something
you pass through?
And geographic mobility makes
friendship more complicated than
it used to be.
» ANN COMPTON: But you can keep
in touch with each other.
» E.J. DIONNE: And that is where
actually you
can be anti-Luddite, because,
you know,
it strikes me with my kids --
sorry -- my students, that they
maintain their bonds in some way
more successfully than we did.
That's a good thing.
But I just -- I sort of like
people to try to think about,
what is loyalty and what does it
demand?  Because it's not
something we talk about much in
our society.
» ANN COMPTON: We have two more
questions coming up.
The next one is from a student
in Hawaii, Jordan.
» Aloha.
My name is Jordan, recent
graduate of the University of
Hawaii.  My idea of the American
dream is freedom.
My question for you is:  What
does freedom mean to you?
» ANN COMPTON: What does freedom
mean to you?  That's just a
small...
» E.J.
DIONNE: This is like a college
interview in reverse.
[ Laughter ]
» ANN COMPTON: And we'll keep
this short because we want to
get to several more questions.
» E.J.
DIONNE: You know, I think
freedom is
about having the capacity to
affect the decisions that are
made that affect you.
Which means that freedom is
partly a
social matter and it's why I am
a
passionate small
ddemocrat and think institutions
should be democratized where
they can be.
And then I think of your -- and
then I
think the first amendment, the
freedom
is sort of described in the
first
amendment, a reasonable list of
what it means to be free.
But I will stop there because I
should stop and let Ross answer,
but these are
a kind of set of liberal
freedoms, and I
also think there's probably
another side of freedom that
I'll let Ross describe that may
have to do with the freedom --
how freedom relates to
responsibility.
» ANN COMPTON: Ross?
» ROSS DOUTHAT: You can't mess
up my answer...
[ Laughter ]
» ROSS DOUTHAT: I have not the
freedom
to answer the question my own
way.
» E.J. DIONNE: I want to control
the conditions on this stage...
» ROSS DOUTHAT: I mean, yeah, I
will -- I guess I'll try to wrap
in what E.J. was referring to.
I think where the American dream
is concerned, I associate
freedom andic I'll sound again a
little like a
radical, but the freedom in
America is not to be a prisoner
of a boss.  You have a boss,
people have bosses, that's part
of life.
But I always come back to a
movie that
maybe is now too old for
millennials to
have seen It's A Wonderful Life
where he plays George Bailey
from Bedford Falls,
New York, and the whole idea
behind George Bailey, he's a
businessman, runs a building and
loan and trying to get people
into their own homes and there's
Old Man Potter, the sort of
Plutocrat of the town who wants
people to rent from him in his
slums.
And the dream of home ownership,
the idea of owning your own home
comes from having a kind of
rooted independence
where you are not a prisoner of,
in his case, a landlord and the
case of being stuck in a job you
don't like, a boss and so on.
And that's -- again, in the
northwestern context I think
that is sort of -- that's the
heart of economic freedom, is
the freedom to sort of make your
own choices for your own family
and have the resources, whether
it's the
money, the car to drive and, you
know,
the territories, all these sort
of icons of American life
connected to that version of
freedom.
And the then to make the
conservative
point, the question -- the
argument that
most American thinkers in the
founding
era and down to the 1950s or
1960s would have made is that
freedom is not the same thing as
license.  And freedom is
confirmed in responsibility.
You want to be free to be --
free to be a moral person, to be
a good person, to be bound by
sort of community rules and
ideas and aspirations.
And that freedom disappears if
it's just treated as a freedom
to do whatever you want.
And that's the kind of society
that ultimately succumbs to
tyranny.  Maximal freedom
ultimately leads
people to want to submit
themselves to some
authoritarian.
» E.J.
DIONNE: Every time a bell rings,
an angel gets its rings.  I love
what Ross just said.
I wrote a column on It's A
Wonderful
Life as embodying the New Deal
ethic.
What is intriguing in that movie
is the moment when George
discovers what
the world would be like without
him and
Bedford Fallless becomes
Pottersville,
and what is so interesting
because of
lack of economic autonomy and
well-distributed property,
Bedford Falls becomes a
gambling, prostitution...  and
to me one of the things I love
about that movie is how it links
the need for economic justice to
the creation of personal virtue.
And anyway, my wife -- we have
hanging
a Wonderful Life poster my wife
gave me one Christmas because I
love that movie.
» ROSS DOUTHAT: But it's an
economic freedom -- it's an
economic opportunity
that is rooted in ownership
rather than dependence, which is
a sort of --
» E.J. DIONNE: But a particular
kind of capitalism.
» ROSS DOUTHAT: Right, yes.
» E.J.
DIONNE: But a social capitalism,
Christian democratized or social
democratized capitalism.
» ANN COMPTON: One more question
coming from Nicole in Hawaii.
Aloha.
» My name is nick comb Tamm, a
student at the University of
Hawaii studying journalism and
Chinese.  I moved here ten years
from Hong Kong with my family.
Our vision of the American dream
is good access to education as
well as the freedom to express
speech and the ways that we can
practice journalism.  My
question to you is:  Do you
think we'll have the same access
to the freedom of speech and
journalism the way we have today
despite immigration policies
that is in place right now?
» ANN COMPTON: Immigration
policies in place right now and
whether the future of freedom of
the press will be there.
» E.J. DIONNE: I sort of have
two thoughts on this that are
kind of intention.
One is I am genuinely alarmed,
as I think Ross is, by the
current administration, its
attitudes toward the media, its
-- you know, its constant
attacks.  The media as the enemy
of the people,
that term the president uses is
a term
that have people band in Russia
because it has memories of
Stalinism.
And I do worry about -- I'm
going to see what has happened
to the kids of parents whoa are
trying to cross the border.
I'm not sure I fully get the
link between the two except that
I -- and
that we've gone through periods
of, you know, restrictionism and
immigration and more open
borders and kind of gotten
through those periods and I tend
to think Americans are
ultimately pragmatic on this
question and they ---they open
up the borders again when they
sort of feel that it's in the
interest of the country.
But I do worry about a general
attitude that is coming from the
government that is authoritarian
and
it's sort of a strong man, if
you will, view of the world that
is very disconcerting.
Having said all that, I think
that we're -- one of the great
things about the U.S. is that we
are really good at correcting
our mistakes.
You know, that line that
everyone loves, always do the
right thing after first
exhausting all of the other
possibilities.
And we're doing one helluva job
of exhausting the possibilities.
» ANN COMPTON: Let me get Ross
in here and then we'll open up
with microphones in the aisle
for you.
» ROSS DOUTHAT: Freedom of the
press issue is a weird one,
because on the one
hand it is extremely unusual to
have the president of the United
States, you know, sweeting
attacks on fake news and, you
know, institutions, including my
employer and so on.
At the same time, the actual
view from inside The New York
Times, and I think
probably from inside the Jeff
Bezos own Washington Post as
well is that in practical terms,
you know, this is the Trump era
has been better for journalism,
maybe worse for everybody else
but better for journalism than,
you know, the five or ten years
before it.
You know, the big threat to the
press in America over the last
10 to 15 years, not to bring
everything back to the evils of
the Internet, has been the
Internet's effect on the media's
business model, and the
fascination and obsession with
Trump and the Trump
administration and so on has,
you know,
been a kind of economic boon in
many ways to the press and at
the same time whatever Trump
himself may want to do, his
administration is not at all in
a position to, I think, clamp
down effectively on the media in
the way
that, you know, see in genuinely
authoritarian countries.
So I am of two minds.
It's obviously a bad thing that
-- you
know, to have a president sort
of de-legitimizing the media, at
the same
time there's a whole weird
Bukuke
theater, Trump atacts The New
York Times and it soars and next
they're on the phone talking to
him because he does that all the
time.
So it's sort of hard to get an
overlead on the situation.
» E.J. DIONNE: Could I just --
» ANN COMPTON: Real quickly.
» ROSS DOUTHAT: I didn't say
anything about immigration.
» E.J.
DIONNE: I think that Trump has
the interesting Trump, the worry
about Trump has been good for a
certain number of
national elite organizations
that basically, like the times
and others in a position to have
a national audience, they worry
very much about journalism at
the local level where the
economic model, you still have
great reporters trying to do
everything they can, but
the number of people covering
state and local government, the
number -- and
these papers don't have the
capacity to build big national
audiences.
» ANN COMPTON: That is not in
the last two years.
» E.J. DIONNE: That's a long
problem.
» ANN COMPTON: It is your turn
now and we will try to make our
answers short to get in as many
questions as possible.
Please raise your hand and we'll
have a microphone come to you.
There's one right in the center
here about --
» E.J. DIONNE: The vital center,
you couldn't be more in the
middle.
» ANN COMPTON: Yes.  Here is a
microphone coming to you from
your left.
Amend
» Is it working?
» We can hear you.
» I'm Katherine Denato,
professor after Georgetown in
school of foreign service.
I'm going to push you guys, both
of you, on the immigration
issue.  Because on the one hand
a lot of what
you said is really interesting,
fascinating, I agree.
On many -- on many points, but I
find your description of the
millennials and young people a
little weak in part because as
one of you said or both of you
may have
said, this is a much -- this
upcoming generation, not just
millennials, but
the post
millennials are more diverse and
foreign born, foreign born
children especially.
I would like to hear a bit more
about the American dream,
freedom and immigration.
» ANN COMPTON: Do we have
another microphone out there
there.
» I'll try to make two quick
points.  The first is to connect
back to the
first question, which is that
one of the
questions for America going
forward is does the society --
does society end up
in this dynamic that you do see
more in California than other
parts of the country where you
have a combination of ethnic and
generational stratification, and
this is part of what drives the
Trump phenomenon and support for
Trump
on the right, but exists in
extremely
liberal
states as well where the
combination of declining birth
rates have created the
phenomenon you described.
A generation much more diverse
and
include ethnic minorities than
40 or 50 years ago co-existing
with an older generation that is
sort of richer and
whiter and obviously older, and
that is a big source of
political attention.
You talk about -- we talk a lot
about class stratification, a
lot about racial stratification.
Having that kind of sort of
ethnic
divide between the generations
tends, I
think, to exacerbate class --
exacerbates polarization and
tension and so on.  So a huge
challenge for America going
forward is, you know, having dug
deep
into policy but to figure out
how
to take a working class that is
increasingly racially diverse
and advance their socioeconomic
interests in
a Peter where there is this sort
of
generational -- alienation
driven by race.  I'm not
providing solutions.
The briefer point I would make
is echo something E.J. said,
when thinking about immigration
tensions we're having now you do
have to recognize there has been
this ebb and flow of immigration
across American history, and the
period that we have
been
talking about as a model of what
American dream would look like
was a
period of extremely low
immigration effectively cut off
by the -- not just
somewhat racist immigration
rules in the 1920s.  I've been
what I would describe as a
moderate immigration
restrictionist over the last ten
years, and, you know, one of the
arguments I made is that you
ended up getting the kind of
extremities of Trump in part
because you had this
very large wave of immigration
that sort of brought America's
foreign born populations up to
levels we haven't had in 100
years and neither political
party took that seriously, sort
of people who -- you know, who
felt that it was happening too
fast, and if you can't take
those concerns seriously, you
end
up empower more demagoguic
alternatives.
I think the alternatives is if
you look at illegal immigration
it's actually down over the past
10 or 15 years and in part some
of the Trump phenomenon is a
reaction to a trend that has
already crested.
It's sort of a delayed reaction
to much larger scale
immigration, especially illegal
immigration in the
early 2000s, and as sort of the
culture internalizes the fact
that the great wave of Mexican
immigration to the U.S. is
probably over, you'll have a
lowering of tensions around that
issue that will lead to better
policies and fewer disasters
like the child separation
policy.  Anyway...
» ANN COMPTON: I'm going to do
one more quick question up here.
» E.J. DIONNE: I'm going to
sneak an answer to your question
into the next one.
» ANN COMPTON: That's good.
» E.J. DIONNE: I've been asked
to move on.
»AUDIENCE MEMBER:  So going off
the
theme of increasing
factionallization, you alluded
to increasing segregation among
other lines, particularly among
educational lines, especially
thinking about the recent
election and how the political
divide is less so between red
states and blue states, more
between blue cities and the red
rural areas.  I'm wondering if
given the centrality of that
idea to the American dream the
idea of society where civic is
with different educational
demographic plantation, what
policies do you think could be
undertaken to minimize
segregation and particularly to
have more integration among
educational and other
demographic lines.
» ANN COMPTON: E.J.
» E.J. DIONNE: That is a
question that I think is central
to the future and that I don't
think we have good policy
answers to yet, because we
clearly have a
situation in the country where
certain
regions are people magnets, job
magnets, investment magnets, a
figure of something like 85% of
the venture capital goes to
three states.
And this is not, as you pointed
out correctly, simple red states
and blue states.
If you compare down state
Illinois to
Metro Chicago, upstate New York
to Metro
New York City or in my state,
you know,
the mill towns, like the one I
grew up
in Lowell or Lawrence or pug
versus greater -- Boston, and
you saw this reflected in voting
patterns.
This is a huge problem and
economist tend to not like
regionally based
economic proposals to try to
lift up one region because they
see it as inefficient.
I heard economists argue what
you do is benefit already
privileged people in those areas
and the benefits don't spread.
But I think there are ways of
pursuing
-- I think we do need to pursue
policies
that are place based and place
based policies would help
different kinds of people on
opposite sides of the divide.
On the one side inner cities who
have
been hammered by
deindustrialization and
on the other hand smaller and --
smaller towns and more rural
areas and factory towns that
have been hollowed out, like
mine.  And I think we just have
to find ways of doing that.  And
I also think we have to find
ways of making so-called bad
jobs better.
There was nothing that said that
working in a steel mill or auto
mill was a good job except
unions came along and
people got paid a good wage,
began to develop benefits, and
we've got to
figure out how to do that again
for jobs in the service sector.
» ROSS DOUTHAT: The best thing
the Trump administration has
done in this regard is to tax
Harvard.
[ Laughter ]
» ROSS DOUTHAT: And I'm not
really kidding.
I think that there is a case for
--
» E.J. DIONNE: He's bitter.
» ROSS DOUTHAT: I'm not bitter.
I've done well with my Harvard
degree.  Here I am on stage with
you.
I think there's room for a kind
of -- for a kind of
experimentation that could cross
left-right lines.  I think
there's a better version of
Donald Trump that, you know,
when Amazon announced it was
going to go on the hunt
for a new corporate
headquarters, that better
version of Trump, instead of
ranting against Bezos on Twitter
would have gotten on the phone
and said, I'm the president of
the United States and I've got a
lot of power, I want to use my
soft power to prevail upon you
to consider going to St. Louis
rather than greater Washington,
D.C.
And, you know, as E.J. says,
that's the kind of things
economists hate and it obviously
kind of smacks a little bit of
authoritarianism
and you could imagine it going
in disastrous directions, but
I'm open to the idea that there
are ways that the
federal government can sort of
use soft
persuasive power around sort of
corporate leadership and also,
you know, tweak and change tax
policies and do a
bunch of things that could treat
these aglom rations of social
and economic capital of
monopolies unto themselves.
It's kind of a monopoly in its
own right.  And the federal
government announced they were
going to move agencies to other
parts of the country, that would
be a small way of starting to
break up that kind of cluster,
and I don't think it would be a
bad thing.
» ANN COMPTON: We're going to
close with one last question
from Hawaii.
The question comes from a
student named Harrison.
» Hi, my name is Harrison.  I'm
a journalism student at the
University of Hawaii.
My version of the American dream
is doing what you love and being
able to provide for those that
love you.  If we do what we love
but can't provide for those who
love us, then how do we as a
society move towards a place
where that can happen?
» E.J. DIONNE: That man should
be a columnist.  Either that or
a preacher.  That was a
beautiful thing.
» ANN COMPTON: It is.  That's
why we wanted to end with it.
So each of you use this as kind
of your closing argument for
tonight.
» ROSS DOUTHAT: I mean, I'll
speak common -- I'll seek common
ground and say that the public
policies we should seek should
be policies that seek a little
more economic equality than we
have right now but that seek it
through by targeting precisely
the areas that the questioner is
talking about.  Basically saying
we're going to provide a little
more support for work and a
little more support for family.
And we're going to reorient the
welfare state so that you have a
little more money when raising
kids, you have a larger earned
income tax credit or something
like it, if you're working a
blue collar job and it gets you
to a place that conservatives
could support because you're
effectively like the GI
bill, you're sort of subsidizing
hard work and child rearing you
gnome, the most conservative
things of all.
But you're doing it in a way
that does
push the society towards a
slightly more egalitarian income
distribution, because I think
that is the core question.
You should be able to -- if you
work hard, you should be able
to, you know, get married, buy a
house and have a family.  And
not everybody wants to do that,
but lots of people do.  And when
America was working at its best,
lots of people were able to do
that, and I think that's a
worthwhile goal for policymakers
today as well.
» ANN COMPTON: E.J.?
» E.J.
DIONNE: The idea of getting to
do what you love is one of the
-- in a way one of the great
privileges of life.
Because there are so many people
who are essential to our lives
who are not necessarily doing
work that they love but work
that they have to do.
And so I think the question is,
you know, in the first instance,
what are the ways of increasing
the chances that people will get
to do what they love,
and that probably has to do with
both access to education on the
one side but
also I think a whole lot more
respect
than we show in our society to
work that
does not necessarily require a
college
degree but reflects class
manship.
I think that one of the -- if
you compare our economy and
social attitudes to the Germans,
I think one of my friends at the
Financial Times has written
quite eloquently about, that
that's society has come to
respect the work done by those
who do not automatically fall
into some meritocratic elite and
has rewarded it accordingly.
And I'm heartened, you know,
bless
Ross for his egalitarian
approach, and it pains me that
there are not very many
conservatives these days who are
willing to embrace that kind of
egalitarianism.
In a way I think more
conservatives, we look back and
think of Robert Taft as deeply
conservative, and yet he was in
that era of shared commitment
created by the New Deal and by
World War II.
He was willing to say that the
market all by itself, the
workings of the market all by
itself will not guarantee the
good life for people.
And I'd like to see us have a
different kind of political
debate where a conservative like
Ross might correct
me in my -- perhaps I have too
much hope in ex-government
program.  Perhaps I would be
more willing to tax people than
he would.
But yet we would share a
commitment to
the idea that you can't make the
-- create the American dream
without individual effort but
you can't create a
society in which the American
dream is possible without some
collective action, some
collective effort, and a real
commitment to each other and not
just to ourselves.
» ROSS DOUTHAT: The irony, it
should be said, since we have
been both in different ways
critical of the President of the
United States tonight, the irony
of the Trump era is that one of
the many
reasonston Trump was
was ---in his bludgeoning way he
did provide that vision.
There is isn't necessarily
policy to
back it up, but the Donald Trump
Republican vision was closer to
what
you're describing than the Paul
Ryan Mitt Romney vision four
years before.
I think that's something that
the
populism of Trump is a sort of
crude grasp at that center that
you're talking about.
» E.J.
DIONNE: What I would argue back
is what is particularly
insidious about what
Trump did is that it carried
that
promise with policies that are
actually antithetical to that
promise.
I always felt, for example, that
when progressives and even
moderates say to a lot of folks
who find at age 507 that
they -- age 50 they are not in a
job that provides them with
income they used to have to
support their families and live
a decent life, and the typical
policy person who happens to be
a
college educated comes along and
says, would you need more
training and education?  There's
truth to that but I think that
person has every right to think,
what that person is telling us
is we've got
to be more like them and it
comes off as condescending and
not in any way genuinely
empathetic.  When Trump said I'm
going to bring back those
factory jobs and coal jobs, of
course he wasn't going to do
that.  I have a strong suspicion
that many people who heard that
and cheered know
that's not true, but they had a
sense from that that he
understood the way they felt
better than the person who kept
talking about training and
education.
So during the campaign, one of
the nicest moments I had was I
suggested
that the hat I wanted to wear
would say "make America
empathetic again.
"  And a very nice person in the
audience came up to me and said,
I love that, you're going to
hear from me! And I got this hat
and got my mail --
it was a perfect for the Trump
hat, but
it said "make America empathetic
again."  But my son said he did
too good a job and it looks like
a Trump hat.
But I do think that we are -- if
our
country dies, it will be because
of our absolute inability to
understand the
suffering and the pain of people
unlike us.
And that the worst kind of
politics is
a politics that holds one
group's pain against another
group's pain.
And that's what we have to find
a remedy for.
» ANN COMPTON: The conversation
tonight
proves that the concept of the
American
dream is this conversation that
is never ending.  Tonight, the
Kluge motto, we've given you a
lot of thought, a lot of call to
action.
Please thank Ross Douthat and
E.J. Dionne for tonight.  Thank
you.
[Applause]
» Here at the Library of
Congress I have one thing to say
to E.J.'s last comment is we
need hats made that say "make
Congress great again."
But thank you for coming.
That's the most important thing,
the audience.  We really
appreciate your attendance
here and we have another
partnership with the Inouye
foundation and have a program
next year.  Stay tuned for that.
We have revamped website of the
Kluge Center so you can keep up
with what we're up to and future
events.  Thank you all again.
[Applause]